maybe you're thinking of applying to
medical schools or maybe you already
applied and received offers you're
feeling excited but also a little bit
nervous while you're moving to another
city or country starting a new chapter
of your life you're going to medical
school of course you'll have to study
hard you want to make sure you do
everything right from the start
well if that's you then hopefully this
video will be helpful for you firstly if
you got into medical school
congratulations you've already
accomplished the hardest part of
becoming a doctor because getting into
medical school is actually a lot harder
than passing medical school exams and
you did that so well done but anyway i'm
zaiha and i'm a fourth year medical
student studying in the uk and these are
the four things i wish i knew before i
started medical school
[Music]
firstly learn how to deal with fomo
google description of fomo is anxiety
that an exciting or interesting event
may currently be happening elsewhere
often aroused by posts seen on social
media you'll see people hanging out with
friends going on holidays finishing
their exams but most of the time when
other people do those you'll need to be
studying when that happens you might
feel like you're wasting away your
twenties you question your life
decisions i mean i had those moments i
asked myself is medicine actually worth
all my efforts and sacrifices because
medical schools give you a lot shorter
holidays compared to other degrees
you'll have half of the holiday time
that other students get and you'll have
less and less holidays as you progress
in medical school i know this might
sound depressing but it's actually not
too bad and there are ways around this
and in medical school your exams don't
end with exam season you'll have many
many more assessments scattered
throughout the year i mean this depends
on your medical school but i'm a fourth
year medical student at the university
of exeter and i have a summative
assessment every week every week on a
thursday i have an assessment that
counts towards my end of degree score
also i have live recorded one of those
assessments when i was in general
surgery if you want to watch me go
through your real assessment you can go
to this minute of general surgery vlog
on my channel but my tip for overcoming
this fomo is that whatever causing this
fomo try to stay away from it usually
social media accounts induce this fear
of missing out like instagram or
snapchat or tick tock then delete those
social media accounts at least for a
while or meet that person's story who's
always posting their daily travels their
night outs whatever that is triggering
you and realize that on social media
people only post best parts of their
lives and understanding that you're not
alone and what you're feeling is normal
can be helpful as well because literally
everyone in this world must have gone
through some sort of fomo and there is
always professional support that you can
get from your tutors at university as
well
[Music]
secondly medical school is not a sprint
it's the marathon i've just talked about
how exam season never ends in medical
school after you go through five six
years of medical school exams then you
think to yourself finally i'm done with
these exams but then you'll need to sit
for specialty exams and so many more to
get even more qualified that's why don't
try and sacrifice your hobbies just so
that you can get a little bit more time
to study because if you do that you'll
burn out what you enjoy doing and the
time you allocate for your family and
friends what fuels you mentally we often
find ourselves saying after i get this
exam done then i'll enjoy myself a
little bit after i get this job done
then i will be happy so after this after
that well you can't say that in life and
especially in medicine because always
something else will come up like you
might need to do training for 16 years
depending on what specialty you choose
so you can't afford to live your life to
the fullest only after your exams finish
because really soon after that there
will be a next one that you'll need to
prepare for so enjoy the journey you
will have free time for yourself and for
what you enjoy doing it's all about time
management and finding your balance
[Music]
you'll have medic friends anyway that's
out of question so i'll be attempting to
explain why having no medical friends is
important for your mental health don't
get me wrong i love my medic friends we
relate to each other and understand each
other on another level we help each
other out and go through five sixties of
medical school together but you'll be
surrounded by medics from the first day
you start medical school until the day
you stop practicing or become retired
this is especially true in the last
three years of medical school so in your
clinical years that is because your
medical school sends you off to middle
of nowhere for months for your hospital
placements the only people that you'll
be seeing during that period will be
your medic friends anyway and trust me
rumors about medical students are true
amongst each other even in our free time
we talk about studies and medicine
that's why having non-medical friends
feels like a breath of fresh air friends
that you connected through your hobbies
and through your values allow you to
have a break from that medical world
seeing non-medical people's lifestyle
helps you realize that medical school
and grades are not everything and it
also humbles you a little bit and helps
to get out of that medical bubble
because that medical bubble you'll be in
can get too much out of topic but that's
why i'd like my life partner to be
someone who's non-medical tips for
making non-medical friends okay usually
medical school campuses are separate and
away from the rest of the university
campuses so making friends from other
campuses requires a little bit more
effort but it's doable you can connect
with people by attending different
societies social events you'll find such
good variety of societies at university
like football volleyball any kind of
sports you can imagine to faith
societies like for christians muslims
buddhists or about veganism or about
countries like japanese american indian
societies so you will find a society for
yourself and everyone in those social
events are usually super helpful and
super friendly so it will be worth it
[Music]
mark twain said all generalizations are
false including this one but i think you
could have imagined that medics do have
big characters not all of them but
you're more likely to find them in this
degree you'll be surrounded by
hard-working and intelligent students
and some of them like to show off their
knowledge intentionally or
unintentionally but this can make you
feel like you're not good enough and you
might compare yourself to them and feel
like you're out of place probably this
feeling feeling less than others might
be new to you because in order to get
into medical school you must have had
good scores maybe you were the student
with top grades back in your hometown
and now you're in a class full of top
students well i did feel that way and
that's okay and if you do too it helps
you realize that you deserve to be in
that class you deserve to be in that
medical school as much as others do
there is a reason why they chose you and
you got accepted to medical school so
even if you don't feel confident or feel
like you don't know enough fake it till
you make it use it for your advantage
and use it as a motivation for you to
study and some students are good at
vocalizing their knowledge and some
aren't as good it's easy to compare
yourself to your peers but try and focus
on your own progress because you know
there is a saying that someone else's
beauty is not the absence of your beauty
or someone else's success is not the
absence of your success
that's it from me hopefully you feel a
little bit more prepared for medical
school now but seriously you'll be more
than fine and i'm excited for you
consider subscribing and liking this
video let me know in the comments which
medical school you'll be going to thanks
for watching and i'll see in the next
one
[Music]